hi man hi david so what we're going to
do in this video is talk about the the
cultural spread of islam where are we
and when are we right now so we are
around the early 7th century
and here we see the byzantine empire
which at the time was still a
continuation of rome so this is like the
eastern roman empire
and it's an aging empire and we also
have sassanid persia which started in
the third century and is still
continuing into this period right so
we've got on the timeline it's going
beyond our start point here yep so these
are two very powerful empires who often
are in tension with one another as you
can see they neighbor each other um and
around this time they're involved in
some pretty pretty powerful uh struggles
here right so in 628 it leads to a lot
of instability within sassanid persia
certainly and in some ways as well the
byzantines are weakened by how many
resources they've exhausted in these
tensions so around this time a new
religion emerges muhammad is born in
arabia
and pretty soon during his lifetime and
immediately after his lifetime the
religion of islam spreads rapidly
through islamic conquest which sal
talked about in an earlier video i mean
just to give you an impression
muhammad died in the year 633 yes so by
750 this is what the state of the
islamic world looked like so they took
over most of persia and a large part of
the byzantine empire
as we can see and then even beyond it
goes further east further west all the
way over to spain
and this happens really really quickly
but it's not the case that islamic
culture necessarily takes
in all of these areas that quickly so it
takes a little bit longer for that to
really take hold and it also takes hold
in areas far beyond this empire as well
so certainly the presence of islamic or
muslim rulers in these areas certainly
did affect the culture of these places
but what's more important is sort of the
the ways in which
islam slowly integrated with some of
these cultures and that happened through
through trade through missionaries
and also through pilgrimage routes that
happened emanating out from mecca and
these religious ideas weren't static as
they moved through different areas and
as they moved through different routes
they changed and they started to take
the shape of the local the local culture
and the local flavor as well so let me
pull up some trade routes
these were the the active trade routes
of the period
and you can see this is a continuation
of the silk road it goes all the way
from rome to china this is xi'an uh
which was then known as
changhan this is the imperial capital of
at least 10 different chinese dynasties
there's also a very large mosque here so
here we have the great mosque at jian
and what's really interesting about this
mosque is that it really fuses a lot of
islamic and chinese ideas so for example
it still sort of has the structure of an
imperial building and in the way that
the courtyards are set up sure but
instead of following sort of the rules
of feng shui
it is oriented towards mecca which is
well the direction in which muslims look
when they pray
but it still has a very chinese
character right
and this makes sense because these trade
routes basically had to go through the
islamic empire and so
as people traveled so did ideas and
those ideas transformed along the way
what's next on our whistle stop tour man
let's look at the mosque in janae okay
so uh janae is in what is today mali
it's just south of timbuktu or tombook
tombok2 as it's called today so it was a
great center of islamic learning and in
janae is the site of the world's largest
mud brick building the grand mosque of
janae let me pull it up
it's a really incredible building that
gets at a lot of
elements of malian culture so this is
the the grand mosque of janae there's a
mud brick building we have an article
about this on khan academy in the art
history section what's really cool to me
about the grand mosque of janae is the
way that it incorporates malian
traditions into islamic tradition so you
can see on top of these spires and some
of these spires are minarets from which
issue the call to prayer
you can't see it in this detail but
there are little ostrich eggs on top of
eggs yeah in mali ostrich eggs represent
um purity and fertility and so even
within the
constraints of building a a religious
building there's still expressions of
local culture
yeah and it's really interesting how
that spread through trade but it also
spread another way which is through
pilgrimage through missionaries through
preachers and that also took on the
local traditions in interesting ways so
let's go to southern to south india okay
near kerala
so this is the chairman juma mosque
this is supposed to be one of the
earliest mosques in history its
construction dates to about 6 30. yup 6
29 to be precise
this was actually during the life of the
prophet and it's quite far from mecca so
it's really fascinating how
quickly it traveled there um but it
traveled with a preacher and um as you
can see this is a very distinctly indian
mosque another way that islam traveled
through preachers was through sufis so
let's talk about sufis for just a minute
sure um sufis were like a mystical
devotional practice and we see many
iterations of sufism in all different
sects of islam
but they were particularly successful at
spreading islam for a few reasons one of
them was that they adopted the teachings
to local traditions and another reason
was that they built lodges and places of
worship along the way and these
sometimes function like community
centers and monasteries so let's have a
look at a couple of them sure let's look
at some north african ones so this is
a rebot in tunisia yes so aribat is kind
of like a hostel you have travelers
staying there um early on in their
history there were soldiers that stayed
there over time they sort of took on a
sort of a monastery culture
for sufis
we also have something called a zauya
so here is an example of one
and similarly this was a place of
learning it was a place of worship
people often lived there for a long time
so they sort of have this like monastic
tradition that created a permanent
presence for islam along these routes
and this was really really integral in
the spread of islam and it's not just in
north africa but even farther east you
see different iterations of that so once
you get into former persian territory
and in indian territory you have
something called a hanka
so here's an example from
kashmir this is called the shahamdan
mosque and it's 14th century mosque and
this is a commemorate a commemorative
building it commemorates an important
sufi leader but again you see some of
the local flavor here you see that
there's some intricate wood carvings
which is really um
very kashmiri very kashmiri certainly
and similarly this was a place of
worship but also a place where people
passed through and interacted and
learned um so it was a site of spreading
islamic tradition as well so that was
about
sorry i should have said that was about
here in srinagar yes about there
um yeah and so in this way islam was
also spread certainly so if you zoom out
a bit let's have a look at sort of the
bounds of the islamic empire sure
and where we see um some of these
instances of
new islamic traditions were no longer in
the heart of the islamic empire we're
beyond that and that's because islam was
carried in many different ways and as we
can see it ended up with some really
really diverse
iterations of islam